per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
momento io sono un barbone e sto sulla
panchina no vabbè io vivo qua però fa
niente del dormo pure per strada perché
non si capisce questa ragazzi sto
facendo questo episodio oggi perché
mentre faccio giochi nella pioggia
esistono posti incredibili nel mondo ad
esempio le isole tropicali se io
schiaccio trasferisci unità familiare
visto che ciò i tordi che su questi io
posso aprendo il telefono durante la
pioggia perché un telefono che repelle
el'acqua posso trasferire la mia vita
familiare completamente da un'altra
parte c'è solani che non è su una
migrazione è un'isola tropicale possa
trasferire la mia famiglia che siamo io
il mio cane
sull'isola è la nuova modalità si chiama
villa sull'isola gli andrà in ambiente
lagunare teoricamente perché mi sembrava
c'è il vulcano addirittura mio dio
ammobiliato live yahoo
sono curioso di vedere come vere
arredano sono contento perché ho sempre
mi è sempre stato il mio sogno di vivere
sull'isola ci siamo trasferiti di notte
sta piovendo ma che figo o perché vivo
incredibile bellissimo peccato che sia
notte che io stia morendo di fame mangia
poi riesce ma io vorrei vivere tutta la
vita qualche figo o vado a vedere quanto
costa negasse sul sorriso
allora vedo che il mio sim si sta
autogestendo quindi questa una cosa
molto buona perché non avevo voglia il
cane sta puzzando laval ho buttato
nell'acqua s'aqua sa cosa fa e ti prego
ti lavi perché ancora ma questa qua mi
seguito anche sull'isola e io la sto
pagando solo a dormire federica sanna
l'altra ma ancora mai seguito qua ma
basta no summer aprirle per favore che
poi un casino puoi tornare a casa tua
brava perfetta ma che bello no ragazzi
fermi questo il mio sogno c'è un'isola
così nella mia vita la voglio adesso
pensate fare lo youtuber nei caraibi
che figata ci vorrà qualora qua come sta
roba cos'è viaggia qui con mai di fianco
a casa mia che viaggia da sola ma
divertimento fame la volta mangia un
panino e poi andiamo a divertirci io mi
butterei a fare un bagno nota senza
vestiti con federica sanna tanto stalla
tafa il portinaio
qua la faccenda si fa molto più bollente
di quello che pensa però non ti denudare
vabbè fa niente se noi ci arrestano però
fa niente ragazzi non guardate questa
maniera gli squali delfini quelli mazzo
però nuota fai qualcosa nota
discuti dell'abito che certo non cela
del regalo della cacca di animale
piccola vai vai vai regalargliela mentre
siamo noi tv un regalo migliore di
questo non potevi riceverlo kakà pico
sun vai via che qui è un casino
guardate come sia messi ma no no no no
no è successo questo video and family
friendly perché tutto censurato però
sono successe cose previsto divertendovi
importate quello nota vicino mali frutto
all'indietro ma che si prova a birillo
dalla boa con la boa a mollo cucina nudo
belli caraibi non devi neanche vestirti
fai tutto così è bello la vita nel cara
mi piace possiamo andare qua che era
tutto il giorno che ci volevo andare con
sabrina prossimi tale sabrina ma con
fair e consap dai chi se ne frega delle
persone vai col mio cane anni col mio
cane
l'unico essere vivente mila
soddisfazione spiaggia di o anali
c'è un tizio all'una e un quarto di
notte che gioca a scacchi da solo ordina
di seguire gli uccelli hasan prova gli
uccelli non se lo stanno pagando di
guarda lo è già messo un'ora a scappare
che gli uccelli lo stavano caricando
neanche per sbaglio
senti però noi che possiamo giocare con
mazza in youtube recapitati con la mia
vita e vabbè è diventata uno scontro di
box infatti lo avevo detto ha messo la
boxe ma com'è possibile
la partita è dura 6 anni guarda arrivata
spettatori per terra stanno arrivando
possibile ma chi ha vinto non si è
capito chi ha vinto ragazzi proprio
grazie dell'hamburger ho vinto io perché
ho vinto la murga chiaro o mio dio che
bella vita
bellissimo vorrei vivere qua tutta la
vita c'è veramente la tua casa non si
limita alle tue mura ma si limita a
tutto quello che hai intorno è
bellissimo non esiste un posto del
genere immagino possa andare al bar
della sabbia posso andarci con nani
posso iniziare a rimorchiare stato
l'altra nomi si caga ragazzi sono al bar
della sabbia ci sarà dato con lei
veramente uscita proprio un fantasy
questo gioco c'è chi è questa ma io ero
venuto qualche un'altra persona dove
andava fini in alani ho perso la tipa ma
è passato un secondo personaggio giuro
ho perso ti fa subito possibile
eccola malanima edizione dispiace so non
so come si mamma mia è messa bene non so
proprio comportarmi e l'ora più felice
per i synth a cagni sono proprio io
totali abbordaggio come funziona si
trova la board aggio subito
vediamo se proprio un fantasy yahoo
mamma mia che fantasia funzionato ma sto
pensando in tutto questo meno meno e va
perché sto puzzando ragazze tu dovresti
lavarti amico mio
poi fare un bagno scusami
talani sala nico che devo andare a
lavarmi faccio schifo non andartene per
favoloso che puzzo lo capisco
pozzo di scarpa morta lo so però non mi
va di tornare al caso adesso il festival
delle spezie raggiungi il festival delle
spese ma sto scherzando
i miei amici con sala nahla nicomede
chiami il festival delle spezie ragazzi
questo volevo vedere questo sarebbe il
al bar per karaoke scattato l'happy hour
ma mi chiamo in paradiso
noi che corrono tutt mamma mia ma
ragazzi ma quant'è bella sta ragazza c'è
ma scusatemi
io mi sono innamorato su se qualcuno di
voi è così chiamatemi vi lascio il
numero descrizione non è vero o forse sì
o forse no
lascio colori pietro nel dubbio dove
dovrebbe essere la sagra delle spezie
direi che ora di provare i gusti noi
regionali ricettario andiamo al festival
delle spese proviamo tutti gli assaggini
da federica sun allora numero uno
mi hai rotto le fa numero due ci sono
già e non sono contenti e mio cibo
attori b togliete grazie ragazzi se non
mi lavo faccio veramente schifo che è
successo lì questo file i cocktail
incredibili elica pica elica pica ma
perché è questo stato a soli potrei
rimorchiare ragazzi l'unico problema è
che sto rimorchiando 85 ragazze tutte
insieme quindi non è proprio il massimo
che lo fa però mi piace rimorchiata sedi
che prova insieme a questo è il bomber
bong rai da maccarone
non è che mi riprendo di tutto questo
nei fondi sulle bolle ma tu con per un
attimo pensavo fosse il bong stavo
diciamo cosa possibile niente anni fa
sono andato io non faccio schifo però
zia sente ascoltami
concludiamo questo è il cosa delegato
guarda però stava parlando del mercato
zio non devi parlare relegato alle
ragazze non capisco un museo non
capiscono questo il controller che mi
permette di cambiare le atipicità quando
faccio i video sto controllarmi permette
di cambiare le e le schermate capito io
faccio così faccio ste cose capito e dai
solo non sono ragazzi interessanti
cioè io parlo delle scatole da capo
vedere anche il green screen ma lo sai
che cos'è
riguardo ti faccio vedere il green
screen è questo se io tolgo il cristo
indietro guarda tutto verde dai capito è
così cioè effetto che escluda dalla
video dai più non so se avete notato ma
ho fatto si cambi spingendo molto
diciamo prima ciavola luce disparate cha
va adesso c'è la luce un po più
funzionale per i video almeno non lo so
me lo dovrebbe dire lei 13
secondo me non è troppo interessata ma
in tutto questo vi dovrei lavare faccio
veramente vomitare chi sono queste zia
io non vorrei dire meglio i capelli non
sono capelli sono tentacoli vabbè io me
ne vado a casa ragazzi devono darmi
scusatemi rimorchiare bello finché non
devi andare
a lavarti quindi questa cosa che
possiamo anche finirla qui posso tornare
a casa
quindi marlena torna a casa cosa dovrei
fare il bagno anche a te però prima devo
pulire me stesso se no un casino sei
molto più profumato to bravo mangia i
rifiuti che così di smaltisci come sono
un educatore di canio non lo è nessuno
my friends direi che questo è abbastanza
per la vita sull'isola molto bello molto
bello
ci sono un sacco di nove carine vorrei
vederle poi tutte successo giorno della
parlata da pirata magliette ma può anche
posto incredibile questo doveva in giro
la gente di parla la pirata ma
incredibile ma che bello ma che bello
non ragazzi sto gioco assurdo che adesso
vado a cercare casa qua e vi porti blog
facciamo prima signori con del gatto con
cui rimorchio e ragazzi spero che
funzioni
venite a casa mia green screen che vi
sia piaciuto come se sì vi è piaciuto
l'argomento vi piace anche a vari social
che come invito dalla descrizione
schiacciate il tasto iscriviti
schiacciate la campanella per rimanere
aggiornati sono i video e noi come
sempre ci vediamo
[Musica]